♪ ♪
>> Emily: NEW SMEARS AGAINST
TRUMP SUPPORTERS FROM THE 2020
DEMOCRATS.
HERE’S MAYOR PETE BUTTIGIEG
TRASHING CHRISTIANS.
>> I’M NOT GOING TO TELL
CHRISTIANS HOW TO BE OTHER
CHRISTIANS, BUT I WILL SAY I
CANNOT FIND ANY COMBAT ABILITY
BETWEEN THE WAY THIS PRESIDENT
CONDUCTS HIMSELF AND ANYTHING I
SEE IN SCRIPTURE.
>> Emily: JOE BIDEN CONTINUES
TO STIR UP
AND SPEAK AT THIS ABOUT PEOPLE
WHO UNFAVORABLE.
>> BY THE WAY, WHAT’S A
PHARMACIST ARE
>> Emily: DANA, HOW DANGEROUS
ARE THE COMMENTS BY MAYOR PETE
TO HIS CAMPAIGN?
>> Dana: TO HIS AUDIENCES, THE
DEMOCRATIC PRIMARY VOTERS, THEY
ARE AGHAST THAT CHRISTIAN
EVANGELICALS WOULD ACTUALLY
SUPPORT PRESIDENT TRUMP AND THEY
CANNOT UNDERSTAND IT AND THEY
CONSTANTLY ARE ASKING THEM AND
RIDING ARTICLES OVER AND OVER
HOW THIS COULD POSSIBLY BE AND
THEY WANT TO SET THE ANSWER.
BUT THE OTHER THING IS TO ME, IF
IT’S DANGEROUS -- I DON’T KNOW
FOR HIM IN THE LONG RUN, BUT THE
GREAT THING ABOUT CHRISTIANITY
IS IT’S NOT FOR US TO JUDGE.
IT’S NOT OUR JOB TO READ
SOMEBODY ELSE’S IN CHARGE OF
THAT.
YOU CAN JUST STOP IT AT THAT
SENTENCE BY SAYING I’M NOT GOING
TO TELL OTHER CHRISTIANS HOW TO
BE CHRISTIANS PERIOD.
>> Emily: JESSE, ARE THOSE
COMMENTS BY BIDEN ANOTHER
INDICATION HE STUCK IN 2016?
>> I DO NOT LIKE THE GAME THAT
POLITICIANS PLAY, YOU HAVE TO
DISAVOW THESE PEOPLE.
ALL IT IS EASY DEMOCRATS MAY
PROVOKE HANDS DISAVOW THEIR OWN
PEOPLE AND IF YOU POINT ON
ANYTHING OTHER ON THEIR SIDE
THEY LOOKED DOWN THE ACT LIKE
NOTHING’S HAPPENED.
PETE BARKING UP HIS
BEFORE HE STARTS POINTING
FINGERS.
IT’S CLEAR THAT AMERICANS HAVE
LITTLE DOUBT WHETHER THEY VOTE
FOR HIM BASED ON HIS LIFESTYLE,
BUT THAT’S NOT MY ISSUE.
MY ISSUE IS -- WHEN HE SAYS
CHRISTIANS HAVE TO SEPARATE WHAT
THEY SEE FROM TRUMP FROM
SCRIPTURE, TRUMP IS THE BIGGEST
CRUSADER FOR THE VALUES THAT
CHRISTIANS HOLD DEAR IN THE
CULTURE WAR.
TALKING ABOUT NOT KNEELING FOR
THE FLAG, APPOINTING PRO-LIFE
JUDGES.
HE SAYS MERRY CHRISTMAS!
IF YOU LOOK AT THE DEMOCRATS,
HE’S FIGHTING A WAR AGAINST THEM
WHO ARE THEN TRYING TO, WHAT,
SOON NUNS OVER OBAMACARE, BOOT
THE PLEDGE OUT OF SCHOOL, AND
PARTIAL-BIRTH ABORTION.
I THINK CHRISTIANS KNOW THAT
TRUMP IS NOT A BORN AGAIN
EVANGELICAL.
THEY SEE HIM FOR WHAT HE IS AND
APPRECIATE THE THINGS HE FIGHTS
FOR, NOT WHAT HE DOES IN HIS
FREE TIME.
>> Dana: GREG, DO YOU HAVE
THOUGHTS ON THE BIDEN COMMENT?
>> I’VE BEEN THOROUGHLY NICE TO
HIM.
BUT I THINK HE IS A PATHETIC
AND, DIMWITTED LOSER.
HE WAS FUMBLING FEEBLE DOLT WHO
NEEDS TO GO BECAUSE THAT WAS A
FATAL ERROR WHAT HE DID BUT WHAT
HE DID IS HE SMEARED TRUMP
SUPPORTERS USING THE EXTREMIST
CONTAMINATION PLOY LIKE, OH, THE
WHITE SUPREMACISTS ARE GOING TO
BE HAPPY SO HE WANTS YOU TO
THINK THAT ANYBODY WHO SUPPORTS
TRUMP SOMEHOW SHARE THOSE SAME
INTENTIONS.
NEVER MIND, JOE, THAT TRUMP HAS
EVER DONE FOR MINORITIES THAN
YOU’VE EVER HAD.
HE’S DONE STUFFER BLACK
COLLEGES, HE’S DONE STUFF FOR
JOBS, WAGES, PRISON REFORM.
JOE, WHAT DO YOU DO, YOU POINT
TO BARACK AND SAY, THAT’S MY
BLACK FRIEND.
I’M SORRY.
WHEN TRUMP BREAKS RECORDS WITH
THE BLACK BELT, SOMEONE SHOULD
WHEEL JOE OUT AND SHOW THEM THE
FACTS.
THAT WAS GARBAGE.
CHUCKLING OVER EQUIPMENT WHAT A
BUNCH OF JACKASSES.
>> Emily: AMY KLOBUCHAR
GETTING
>> MY NAME IS AMY AND WHEN I
TOOK SPANISH IN FOURTH GRADE, MY
NAME WAS ELENA.
BECAUSE I COULDN’T ROLL MY RS
VERY LOUD.
IT WAS E-L-E-N-A.
>> Geraldo: YOU KNOW, I JUST
THINK BRIEFLY THAT I THINK BIDEN
IS GUILTY OF WHAT I SEE VERY
COMMONLY, ASK A DEMOCRAT, DO YOU
THINK ALL REPUBLICANS ARE
RACIST, AND TO MANY OF THEM
HESITATE BEFORE THEY RELUCTANTLY
SAY NO.
IN TERMS OF THE HISPANIC VOTE, I
THINK THIS IS A VOTE THAT’S UP
FOR GRABS.
THE PRESIDENT HAS IN HIS HARSH
LANGUAGE LEFT AN OPENING FOR THE
DEMOCRATS TO EXPAND HIS BASE.
SPEAK WITH COMPASSION ABOUT THE
POPULATION, THIS IS A POPULATION
THAT YOU CAN -- THESE ARE
ENTREPRENEURIAL PEOPLE,
FAITH-BASED PEOPLE, FAMILY
ORIENTED PEOPLE, THESE PEOPLE
COULD BE REPUBLICANS AS
GEORGE W. BUSH FAMOUSLY SAID, I
WANT THE PRESIDENT TO BE MUCH
MORE EXPENSIVE AND KINDER TO THE
WHOLE BORDER ISSUE, YOU CAN
BUILD THE DAMN WALL, I DON’T
CARE.
BUILD A DORK AND HE SAYS THERE’S
GOING TO BE A DOOR APPEAR THE
PRESIDENT NOW HAS A HISTORIC
OPPORTUNITY TO EXPAND THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY IN THE WAY THAT
WE HAVE NOT SEEN SINCE
RONALD REAGAN IN HIS SECOND
TERM.
THIS IS HUGE AND HE CAN DO IT.
JUST THE GUY TO DO IT.
I’VE SEEN HIM WORKING IN THE
AFRICAN-AMERICAN COMMUNITY.
I WANT TO HELP HIM GET THAT
LANGUAGE, FOR THE DACA STUDENTS,
THE DREAM ACT STUDENTS.
THESE ARE PEOPLE YOU WANT TO
BRING INTO THE AMERICAN DREAM.
LET’S DO IT.
>> Emily: IF THOSE VALUES ARE
SHARED REGARDLESS OF NATIONALITY
OR A COUNTRY OF ORIGIN, WOULD IT
THEN BE ATTRACTIVE TO THE
POLICIES THAT HAVE BEEN
FURTHERED BY TRUMP AND RESULTED
IN HIGHER WAGES, ACHIEVING THE
AMERICAN DREAM?
>> Geraldo: SOMETIMES YOU HAVE
GOT TO PLAY TO A CERTAIN CROWD.
IT DOESN’T TAKE A LOT.
THEY ARE THERE AND OPEN, THEY
LOVE TO BE LOVED.